we live in a hyper partisan age these
days people seem to identify with
political parties and political
movements even more than they do with
their favorite football team
and that's remarkable or something
that's really just a voluntary
Association which is what political
parties are the government doesn't
create political parties people do
they're essentially private clubs in
most democratic constitutions political
parties aren't even mentioned and yet
they've become an integral part of
nearly every functioning democracy
frustration with political parties is
nothing new the American founding
fathers absolutely hated them in his
farewell address George Washington the
first president of the United States
famously warned the young country the
political parties would enable cunning
ambitious unprincipled men to subvert
the power of the people and usurp for
themselves The reigns of government
John Adams the second president said
that the vision of society into
political parties should be dreaded as
the greatest of political evils
despite warnings like these political
parties have become important
unavoidable features of democratic
government
well today we'll take a closer look at
political parties we'll talk about what
they are and how they differ around the
world and we'll see that as frustrating
as they can be political parties are
essential for the functioning of a
healthy democracy
finally we'll get a sense for why some
democracies have many political parties
where there's others have just two and
will consider the relative advantages
and disadvantages of two and multi-party
democracies
but first what are political parties and
what do these strange institutions do
that make them so reviled and yet such
important features of the political
landscape
political parties are organizations that
attempt to gain and maintain political
power and to influence public policy
usually by participating in elections or
by helping their members attain
political office
now you'll notice that I say usually and
that's because campaigning for office
and winning elections that's what
political parties do in stable
functioning democracies
but in Dysfunctional States and
dictatorships political influences
sometimes achieved by other means like
violence or intimidation and political
parties play an important role in places
like that too
take for example Hamas which is a
political party that operates in the
Palestinian territories Hamas advocates
for Palestinian sovereignty and also for
the Palestinian Authority to adopt
stricter islamist political policies but
Hamas also has a military Wing if
elections don't go your way or if you
want to make sure that they do go your
way it's helpful to have an armed
militia that way you can provide
security for your members intimidate
opponents or carry out actions on behalf
of your supporters
in fact in places with weak or
dysfunctional governments like the
Palestinian territories political
parties often step in and perform the
functions that a government normally
would they build schools and hospitals
and they provide security and even
collect the trash and they basically do
the things that the real government
either can't or won't do
and they do this at least in part with
the resources they collect either in the
form of taxes which is what you might
call it if you support their activities
or extortion which is what you'd call it
if you don't it turns out that the
difference between extortion and
Taxation is kind of like the difference
between terrorists and freedom fighters
from the outside the activities look the
same the difference is a matter of
perspective
and so especially in places where
Democratic institutions are weak or
non-existent political parties often
have Associated or at least closely
Allied security forces the Nazis had the
brown shirts the African National
Congress in South Africa had a group
called the Spear of the nation and in
Northern Ireland the Nationalist
movement known as Shin Fein had the
provisional Ira the Irish Republican
Army and to steal a phrase from should
fein's strategy book these organizations
aim to represent their supporters with a
ballot paper in one hand and a machine
gun in the other
political parties also play an important
role in authoritarian regimes that is to
say in countries that have functional
but non-democratic governments
Cuba Venezuela China Nazi Germany and
the former Soviet Union these were all
party dictatorships or one-party States
in places like this political parties
often become recruiting training and
propaganda organs of the dictatorship
itself
let's face it the same tools that
political parties use to win elections
advertising persuading even educating
the public although same tools are also
important things for dictators to use
once they've attained political power
but of course when we talk about
political parties we're usually thinking
about organizations that compete for
power in the context of a stable
democracy in elections and campaigns and
in the houses and Halls of legislative
assemblies democracy is about
competition and so too are political
parties and that's what we're going to
focus on today
so what role do political parties play
in a modern democracy well for one thing
political parties help the electorate
make informed decisions let's face it
we're all busy we have things to do and
sometimes we don't have time to follow
politics as closely as we might
otherwise want
well it turns out the political parties
help us make accurate political
decisions that is decisions that
actually represent our views and they do
this by acting as a kind of shorthand or
abbreviation for what our
Representatives stand for
example when I vote for a minor
political office I might not know a lot
about John Doe's particular views on
this or that political issue
but next to John Doe's name on the
ballot I'll often see an r or a d
signifying that he's a Republican or a
Democrat and this helps me know if I'm
likely to share John Doe's views even if
I don't know much about him as an
individual
I don't know what John Doe stands for
but I do know what most Democrats stand
for and so when I see that little D next
to his name I can make a pretty good
guess as to whether or not I want to
support him and no it it's not a hundred
percent like any abbreviation you lose a
little information when you vote
strictly along party lines but it's a
lot better than a random guess and so
for down ballot races that little r or D
can be a helpful piece of information
political parties also help people
coordinate their efforts with other
people who have similar political views
this is important because sometimes what
you do is dependent not just on what you
yourself want but on what you think
other people are likely to do
let's say that at the start of a
presidential election you had one
right-wing candidate and dozens of
left-wing candidates if you don't have
political parties if each of those
left-wing candidates ran as an
individual well they'd be competing with
each other for votes on the ballot from
the liberal end of the spectrum and
doing that might unintentionally hand
victory over to the other side
in that case the right-wing candidate
would win not because he or she had more
support but instead because the
left-wing candidates couldn't coordinate
their actions and decide which one of
them should run
that's why it's usually advantageous for
people on the same side of the political
Spectrum to form an organization a
political party that broadly speaking
represents the views that they have in
common and which has certain procedures
for deciding who among them is going to
run
that way the candidates can compete with
one another before the general election
but then pick a single nominee and
everybody else can get behind that
nominee and give that person a real
chance of beating the other side
in the United States this preliminary
process is called a Party primary it's a
very public process one that gives
ordinary citizens a lot of say in each
party's eventual nominee but in many
other democracies the process is more
closed and the selection of a party's
nominee is really done by the
card-carrying members of that political
party often at a party convention or
meeting
this difference has received a lot of
attention in recent years the closed
nature of most other countries nominee
selection process gives establishment
candidates there a real advantage but
because it's much more open and public
party primaries in the United States
sometimes allow Outsiders and relative
newcomers to appeal directly to the
electorate bypassing the establishment
figures who have more Cloud within the
party bureaucracy
now whether you think this is a good
thing or a bad thing is up to you but
it's fair to say that if the U.S used a
less public method of selecting nominees
an outsider like Donald Trump would have
been very unlikely to secure the
Republican Party nomination in 2016.
the larger point to keep in mind is that
political parties serve an important
function by providing a process for
people to pick a common nominee or set
of nominees people with similar
political views can avoid competing with
one another and thereby increase the
chances that their views will win
representation
once in office political parties also
promote stability and open up
possibilities for compromise if a
legislature consisted of a hundred
individuals rather than just a handful
of political parties it's hard to see
where the process of negotiation would
even begin it'd be a complete
free-for-all but political parties allow
the members of a legislature and thus
the political factions in society to
negotiate to form coalitions and to make
deals as a smaller number of voting
blocks as chaotic as democracy sometimes
is imagine how much worse it would be if
the debate wasn't among a handful of
political parties but a free-for-all
among hundreds of individuals in an
assembly
so it can be very good and even a sign
of democratic health for a country to
have stable political parties
with coherent policy platforms and a
process for picking nominees and I know
that this is a tough argument to make at
a time when political parties and major
partisanship seem to be tearing
countries apart
but just this too much partisanship can
lead to tribalism too little
partisanship can make the electoral
process and even the governing process a
complete mess that's why partisanship
taken in moderation can be a sign of
political health
all right so if that's why political
parties emerge why do more political
parties emerge in some countries
compared to others why does the United
States have just two dominant political
parties whereas Germany has five or six
in places like the Netherlands or Israel
have dozens each with a realistic shot
of winning parliamentary seats and
serving inner ruling coalition
well in a way that's part of the answer
right there Coalition politics in a
place like the United States where
there's a single and very powerful
president most people don't want to vote
for a third party even if they like what
it stands for because there's only going
to be one president and voting for a
third party candidate can feel like
throwing away your vote
but if there's a realistic chance of
Coalition politics of a prime minister
building a coalition of a few political
parties well in that case the situation
is a little different
now voting for a minor party isn't
throwing away your vote because the
small party if even if it can't win the
prime ministership can still play a
meaningful role in the governing
coalition
this is just one of the reasons you're
more likely to see multi-party politics
in parliamentary political systems and
two-party politics in presidential
systems
a similar thing happens at the local
level and this can be another reason why
some systems have a tendency to see the
development of just two competitive
political parties rather than many
in the United States and in the United
Kingdom and in a handful of other
countries we generally have one
parliamentary or one congressional
representative per District everyone in
the United States has one and only one
representative in the House of
Representatives unless you live in
Washington DC in which case you have
zero
but you could imagine a system where
each legislative district had say two or
three Representatives or even more all
of whom run for office at the same time
and it turns out that having multiple
Representatives per District also tends
to enhance the number of competitive
political parties
let's say you had a legislature with 200
members but only 100 districts with each
district electing two Representatives we
call these multi-member districts rather
than single member districts notice how
in that case voters no longer feel
penalized for voting for third parties
your third party vote might be enough to
put your preferred candidate in second
place rather than third and in a
two-member district that would be enough
for that person to win a seat
so in comparative politics we see a
clear Trend first discovered by the late
political scientist Maurice du version
and therefore it's called du verges law
and this trend suggests that single
member districts will usually give rise
to the creation of just two dominant
political parties whereas when the
number of Representatives per District
goes up so too does the number of
competitive political parties
for good or for ill the use of single
member districts is yet another reason
why the U.S and the UK seem stuck with
their two-party dominant system
in fact there are political systems
where voters vote for political parties
rather than individual candidates and
these voting systems also tend to
increase the number of political parties
sometimes quite dramatically
these are called party list election
systems and they're used in a lot of the
world's multi-party democracies Italy
Spain Portugal Israel and in a host of
newer democracies in Eastern Europe
Poland Romania Bulgaria and so on and
they use a close variant of the system
in the Netherlands Switzerland and
Scandinavia
the thing with party list voting systems
is that they're perfectly proportional
voters vote for a party not a person and
then whatever percentage of the votes
that party gets that's how many seats
the party gets in the legislature this
kind of radical proportionality has a
tremendous effect on the party system
and thus on the character of democracy
more generally
think about it a political party that
gets just six percent of the vote well
in a list system will now get about six
percent of the seats this wouldn't be
enough to win the top job like the Prime
Minister ship but it might be enough to
get a place in the ruling Coalition
contrast this with a single winter
District where a tiny political party
probably wouldn't win anything at all
moreover these political parties aren't
just small they're often specialized and
focused on a narrow set of issues let's
face it if you only have to win a few
percentage points to get seats in
Parliament you can afford to cater to a
pretty narrow slice of the electorate
but despite their small size and narrow
Focus minor political parties can wield
tremendous influence
take a case like the Netherlands which
uses a variant of the party list system
and which consistently has a dozen or so
political parties in its House of
Representatives
and to give you a sense for how narrowly
tailored these parties can be there's an
animal rights party in addition to two
green parties and there's a 50-plus
party which advocates for pensioners and
retirees you see what I mean by catering
to relatively small segments of the
electorate
and sure some of these parties only have
a few seats each but there are so many
political parties and the votes are so
spread out that even the major parties
only have 20 or 30 percent of the seats
this means that the bigger political
parties need the smaller ones in order
to get a majority and to get anything
done
in the Netherlands you're usually not
going to be able to form a government or
to pass laws without a handful of
parties in your Coalition whatever is
necessary to get you past the 50 mark
in a multi-party democracy tiny
political parties can have
disproportionate influence
what's important to remember is that the
number of political parties has only a
little bit to do with how divided or
fractured a society is
parties can factionalize or divide or
they can coalesce and merge around a
broader set of interests but this isn't
really a function of how factualized
Society is or of how many interest
groups there are instead it reflects the
ways that votes are counted and that
seats are filled or it's a function of
the government formation process and the
capacity for coalitions the United
States has two dominant political
parties not because people necessarily
want it that way but rather because the
way we hold elections
disincentivizes us from voting for small
political parties for fear that we'll be
throwing away our vote if the United
States had parliamentary coalitions and
party list voting new political parties
would almost certainly emerge and if the
Netherlands went to majority voting the
parties there would likely consolidate
knowing that if they don't get a sizable
chunk of the electorate they might not
get anything at all
okay but is that something we should
want is the multi-party system really
better
well not necessarily it's true that a
lot of people find the multi-party
system appealing they they like that
it's proportional they say it promotes
broader coalitions and provides more
opportunity for compromise and consensus
most of all they like that it gives
voters a lot of choice
you're a socially conservative tree
hugger there's probably a party for you
you want less regulation in the economy
but also legalized marijuana that's what
the libertarian party is for and in a
multi-party system they have a realistic
chance
I was talking to a friend just the other
day this person describes herself as a
social justice Catholic among other
things she wants to see restrictions on
abortion but she also opposes the death
penalty what's more she wants to see the
government fund private religious
schools which her kids attend but she
also wants to see more public support
for the poor and for immigrants
and I had news for her in the current
two-party system she's bound to be
disappointed right now there just isn't
a political party in the United States
that represents the the full complement
of her political interests
multi-party systems on the other hand
give voters more Choice with a dozen
political parties you're more likely to
find a group that represents your
particular combination of political
interests or you might even find one
political party that represents the
narrow set of issues about which you're
particularly passionate that's probably
why multi-party systems usually have
higher voter turnout and higher levels
of Engagement than two-party systems the
relative lack of choice in a two-party
system can lead to apathy people get
tired of compromising their values and
of voting for what they see is the
lesser of two evils
in multi-party systems political parties
can get away with catering to a small
but passionate subset of the electorate
and this has a way of enhancing
political participation
still the multi-party system's greatest
assets diversity of representation
proportionality and choice these things
are also its biggest liabilities
the problem with giving everyone a
choice is that you also give everyone a
voice for every 50 plus political party
that caters to pensioners and every
green party that caters to
environmentalists there's probably a
Communist party or a fascist party or a
party with fringe extremists that want
to put an end to the democratic system
itself
the German Nazis Rose to prominence in a
highly factionalized multi-party
democracy and I think that's why people
today are so wary of seeing small
populist political movements to the
right and the left gaining political
power
extremist views often start off as
Fringe views and just as the multi-party
system gives small factions
disproportionate influence it also gives
them a stage and a path to enter the
mainstream
we see this in the multi-party
parliaments of Hungary and Poland Greece
and Spain Austria and Germany and even
in the Netherlands one of the oldest and
most stable democracies in the world
when political parties represent narrow
segments of society they have a tendency
to represent extremist segments of
society but then again no political
system is perfect the two-party system
can provoke gridlock and US them
thinking and that too offers a sad path
to democratic decay
ultimately two-party and multi-party
democracies both come with risks and
Rewards the choice of which is better
remains one of the enduring questions of
comparative politics